okay today I'm going to talk to you
about the reactivity series underneath
is an example of the reactivity series
all that it is is a list of different
elements the most reactive is at the top
and as we go down we get less and less
reactive until we get down to the bottom
and we have the least reactive elements
near the bottom now you don't need to
learn the reactivity series you just
need to be able to apply knowledge about
it now the reason why I've done carbon
and hydrogen in a different color and
these are nonmetals all of the rest on
here are metals it's just important to
know these because carbon it comes in
when we think about reduction with
carbon and hydrogen we need to know when
it comes to reactions with acids so it's
a bit of information we need to know is
about oxidation now oxidation means a
reaction with or addition of oxygen so
the elements at the top for example
potassium is very very reactive so as a
result potassium is the easiest to
oxidize it oxidizes very very readily
that's why it's right near the top and
as you go down it becomes less and less
easy to oxidize right until you get to
the bottom of gold which is the most
resistant to oxidation okay so we can
also use reactions with acids and with
water in order to learn more about the
reactivity series so let's imagine I've
got five different test tubes each of
them contains hydrochloric acid so we're
going to see what we'd find if I reacted
each one with an acid so we're looking
at reactions with acid
so when I add the metal and the acid
together I get a salt being produced and
hydrogen gas now we can see this and we
can see the different reactivities based
on the reactions with acid so let's say
I take something that's quite high up
the reactivity series something it's
quite reactive such as magnesium if I
take magnesium and I put it into my
hydrochloric acid so I just labeled one
with HCl so we know that's hydrochloric
acid then we could see we'd have a very
vigorous reaction remember hydrogen is
being produced when we react a metal
with an acid and we'll see loads and
loads of bubbles being produced here now
the test for hydrogen is called the
squeaky pop test now what you do is you
hold a lit splint over the test tube and
if there's a squeaky pop then we know
that hydrogen is present now this
squeaky pop would be really really loud
so we can test these with different
metals so the next one let's say we've
got aluminium there which is one down
the reactivity series then we'll have
zinc here iron here and in the final one
copper so what we'll find with each of
these let's say each of them is the same
strength of acid the same volume of acid
and the same mass of metal what we
should find is each one will have a
slightly less vigorous reaction with
hydrochloric acid so with this one it
will produce hydrogen at a very quick
rate there'll be a lot there loud
squeaky pop and a large one then this
one would have a slightly quieter
squeaky pop and slightly fewer bubbles
being produced at a slightly slower rate
and so on until we got to copper which
will have no reaction at all the reason
why copper does not react with
hydrochloric acid is because if we have
a look at the reactivity series copper
is below hydrogen so as a result it is
not react with with hydrochloric acid
now it's not just
acids
that metals can react with of really
really reactive metals such as potassium
and sodium these ones up here
they're so reactive that they react with
water now I'm just going to show you an
example using potassium so potassium
plus water makes potassium hydroxide and
hydrogen so just balance that quickly so
again
hydrogen is being produced so again we
could use a squeaky pop test to test for
this now some of these so zinc and iron
for example they don't react with water
they're not reactive enough to react
with water by itself but they can react
with steam so we have a simple
experiment to do that all you have is a
boiling tube like this with a bung in
the end and some and you have some
mineral soaked in water mineral wool
soaked in water so that's wool soaked in
water and in the boiling tube you might
have that bit of iron so this is this
bit here now when you heat up the wool
the water evaporates it travels over the
iron reacting with the iron in order to
produce hydrogen so if you like the end
you should be able to light so that
basically is the reactivity series most
reactive or the top less reactive at the
bottom when you test them with acids
there'll be a more vigorous reaction and
allowed a pop with squeaky pop test when
you test higher up the reactivity series
at the very top they do react with water
otherwise they're a little bit lower
down they'll have to you'd have to react
them with something like with with steam
instead rather than just cold water and
that's the reactivity series thank you
very much